yet another plan of the UK funded
integrity initiative has surfaced and
their fight against misinformation they
expose networks that's out to identify
civil society organizations operating
across Europe countering disinformation
upskill these organizations in research
and communications and through the
provision operational support grants and
training and coordinate their activities
the documents are the seventh part in a
string of leaks that began in late 2018
the outline plans for the exposed
Network a web of European wide companies
combating misinformation the documents
map illustrates just how wide it is
stretching from the UK across to Eastern
Europe according to their terms outlined
in the documents participants are
required to handle sensitive information
for the state and they also need to sign
a strict non-disclosure agreement as for
who is spreading the misinformation well
most parties seem to have a fixation on
Russia
[Music]
State we've been targeted by the Russian
media the Russians governments as
criticizes directly and that's not going
to stop us because there's so many of us
who can do this we're gonna keep going
well another striking example a
Ukrainian media watchdog called detector
media it's responsible for monitoring
the professional quality of news and
television programs in the Ukraine to
them a pro-russian position could be
considered a violation of professional
standards have a look at this article
about the Ukrainian intelligence
services performing raids against what
they call pro-russian media the watchdog
was disappointed at how little the
government succeeded with their
patriotic agenda those organizations may
or may not have accepted money from the
integrity initiative nevertheless
exposes planned budget is around three
million pounds annually from 2018 to
2021 and it's not like the British
government didn't throw millions of
pounds at integrity initiative last year
the government are funding this
initiative with nearly two million
pounds this financial year although when
government misinformation is the concern
it might be hard to be sure your
government isn't the culprit even if the
integrity initiative does they do stop
funding these activities you're gonna
find that Western governments will be
diverting their resources to another
organization in order to engage in
propaganda people in the West need to
become aware of the extent to which
powerful actors governments big business
engage in manipulation of public
perceptions for political and economic
purposes this thing is bigger than the
integrity initiative and it's been going
on for much longer than integrity
initiative
seem to me that the mainstream media is
doing its job bringing to the attention
of Western publics this kind of
propaganda operation I think in Western
European politics were aware of all this
they would be cross angry and outraged
and now being subjected to this kind of
manipulation footnote to the story the
integrity initiative says its websites
now closed pending an investigation into
the theft of data responding to earlier
leaks the organization denied any covert
activities and said much the published
material was I dated I can also tell as
well
we sent a request to the British Foreign
Office regarding the latest batch of
leagues so far no response
you